hey good afternoon everyone thank you
for joining us today for this webinar on
virus rushing where we will discuss an
ending in examining how to position your
brand and organization in times of
crisis this session is brought to you by
chemistry team in partnership with so
now and ultra-super knew and is
supported by design Singapore Council
the National Agency for design in
Singapore and the Design Centre so this
webinar and virus Rossing is part of
national design centers lineup in June
with a female Khateeb focus on building
stronger brain chemistry team is honored
to be invited to contribute to this
discourse on how brands can tribe and
emerge stronger in the competitive world
today and let's get started and so
please allow me to introduce son carrier
who's expert in circular economy and
sustainability founder and CEO of so now
she works with a broad range of
organization from the public sector and
the private sector to adopt sustainable
and circular economy model and
jean-francois theory ahead of growth at
ultra-super new a marketing and
advertising expert always on the lookout
for new opportunities and trends in the
market he manages clients relation to
develop new verticals and ventures and
drives the business performance to both
agencies and brands across a pack baby
son you can speak a little bit more
about yourself and all yes of course
thank you
Romina for introducing me yes on this
slide I get the opportunity to speak a
little bit about so now started in 2009
addressing sustainable economics started
in the Netherlands but always knew that
scaling is be done in Asia so second
branch opened in Singapore in 2017 and
we now have projects all over as Ian and
Japan on the next slide you will see the
core of our business which is creating
circular economy yes where we can see
that in the current economy we generate
a lot of waste
we don't treat our planet that well
we're not that good at fairy supply
chains but then in a circular economy we
keep everything that we use we keep in
the loop so we have a practice for
sustainable economics and in that
fashion we need a very strong partner to
help the brands that practice these good
practices to achieve adherence
storytelling and therefore we work
together with ultra super new so on the
next slide I would introduce Sean to
introduce the company and himself thanks
Ann hi everyone
yeah so as previously mentioned I'm the
head of growth our discipline who we are
a creative agency originally founded in
Japan in 2007 and we now have three
offices in the kaga the APEC region with
Singapore opening up what four years ago
and I went at the beginning of this year
so it's a creative agency if I could
just share a little bit about specialty
lies we have got a name for ourselves in
helping brands both traditional
companies and new economy companies
reach out to the Genji and millennial
audience so we help them with their
brand repositioning we help them build
their communication tool kids we help
them build like active marketing
activities on social digital activation
to make sure that your message is
getting across the right way to that
particular audience yeah so that's just
a short introduction to what we do as
agency and over back to you Romina yes
so hi everyone my name is Romina I'm a
business designer at chemistry and a bit
more about chemistry we are strategic
design consultancy and you can see our
shop house on the picture on the left
unfortunately we can't go back right now
because we're still in economic close
down but besides this we have office in
Singapore and an outlet that was
recently open in Amsterdam as well we
apply the Design Thinking human centered
approach in problem-solving and
designing solutions for our users and
also aligned with business and our
organization that we work with so that's
for chemistry
back to our main topic we are talking
today about virus washing but what is
really virus washing Sun maybe you can
tell us a little bit more about this
yeah what we see is that on the next
slide and we've put together a
definition to make it easier that we
have common ground of what we are
actually addressing so we see under
current circumstances that as a result
of kovat 19 besides a lot of brands that
and organizations that are doing their
utmost best to support their communities
by entering in campaigns that will help
their community to go through to get
through this crisis together there is
also brands that are a bit less
transparent about their practices or
their ultimate goals so for this seminar
and beyond we would like to coin fire
smashing as the exploitation of code 19
for the self enrichment of a brand or
organization and this might seem like a
pretty strong claim we want to stress
that it's not absolutely us to judge or
to - any brands or organizations but
what we want to show is that how
communication in the field of a crisis
or of sustainability can go either very
well and really aligned with what the
community needs but that there is also a
lot of bad practice out there so we hope
to give you that lens so that you could
use it to also research your own
communication in these times yeah so
there are definitely a few recent
examples that we've seen of virus
washing and one that's that Jean you
want to highlight about right yeah I
mean like what son said you know we're
not really here to say all right I would
not any position to really tell people
that what you are doing is wrong of
course these are all just purely
opinions of what we think and ended up
quick doing more harm than good and I
think over the past couple of weeks with
everything that's been happening
well first Cove it and after that the
black lives matter movement we've seen a
large spike in demand for brands and
people and and influences and companies
to take a stand you know and my gut
feeling you know is that this situation
is created damned if I do damned if I
don't scenario where you know people are
just looking at brands to to say
something and and that has really
created a like a trigger in the sense
where we're not really thinking twice
before putting brand messaging out so
this is an example which I which I
happened to come across a couple of
weeks ago in Brazil with McDonald's
using this opportunity to increase their
share voice by standing in solidarity
and it did this by you know separating
the signature arches and this actually
kind of backfire with a lot of consumers
on on Twitter questioning them or was
the real intent behind his exercise you
know a lot of things were pointed out
like maybe was a much better approach
would have been to give their workers
paid leave to minimize human contact
instead of you know launching this
message bad exercise another example
there's a personal favorite of mine I
mean you know as an organization we need
PETA because they are championing
something that's really important but
again you know using the using this is
opportunity to further its own agenda
actually backfire on them you know this
attempt felt quite felt quite flat you
know with people mocking the brand and
what it stood for online you know tell
you what it wasn't the desired outcome
that they hoped for yeah so any of
anything to add to this yeah whatever I
find interesting and it hurts me a bit
because I find Pizza a very important
organization but they are basing this
claim of the link between eating meat
and the coronavirus as like a direct
result or a to be connection but if you
need like read the tech line below they
know that it's not that strong a claim
so they know that it's only a hunch that
currently scientists have that by eating
dead flesh you would be more eligible to
get the virus
and we really believe that this is a
claim that could have been rephrased and
perhaps the check that the the the
effect checking behind it could have
been more elaborate because we think it
doesn't support the cause of the
organizationís as such yeah for sure I
believe that there are a lot of brands
who dare try to take advantage of the
situation to share a message across that
Rizzy really doesn't align with what
people expect but I do believe also that
there might be some good practices out
there that we can inspire ourselves from
and that share a more positive message
in the approach especially when it comes
to virus washing right yeah on the next
slide you will see maybe you can play a
video yeah
can you guys see the video right now
just checking okay great
so tell us more about this video
actually maybe wanted to play yeah so
Canaries one of the biggest shows I mean
this is an American campaign after all
but what they did was the part of United
Way a non-profit to share message of
generosity and I think this was
extremely relevant because due to the
coffee 19 situation and the lockdown it
placed a large amount of stress on you
know establishments and businesses to
provide home essentials for people
knocked down and it was always a matter
of who could buy more at the start and
and hard and ended up holding a lot of
uses and chose leaving people who
actually needed it not having the
ability to access such products so this
campaign in policy right away called on
people to you know share a square we
shared toilet roll toilet paper to those
who really need it you know encouraging
generosity banking on the human spirit
during this period of crisis I thought
this was extremely well thought-out
campaign you know and and and they
really hit the nail on the head with
this and there is only that much toilet
paper that you can use right yeah I also
believe that here in Singapore we needed
the governments to explain that
everything as a strong young person you
could port during times of crisis is
also products or services that cannot go
to the weaker or elderly and that we
needed this reminder to actually
understand what we're doing when we are
out of fear and hoarding products like
toilet paper or rice and so I'm happy
that there are also demands out there
that pick this up and strike for a more
equal distribution definitely question
do you have any other examples maybe yes
there is a local example that that is my
personal favorite we can see it on the
next slide I think everybody knows these
containers of soy sauce that we get when
for takeaway sushi or Japanese cuisine
and what we saw in Japan is that the
the factor of these fishes the their
turnover decreased rapidly because there
were little events a lot was canceled so
they saw a decrease in production and
demand for their soy sauce containers on
the other side there was an increasing
demand for hand sanitizer and we
couldn't scale up fast enough to provide
the hand sanitizer to people in Asia so
the two companies they started working
together the soy sauce containers so the
fishes they are reusable and they now
contain hand sanitizer and we feel that
this is just such a simple solution
through which you can show that you use
your business sense and it's still okay
to provide this as a commercial service
but then have a service offering that is
really really speaking to the public
yeah we've seen a few manufacturers
actually that I've shifted their supply
chain in order to provide this hand
sanitizing options out there to make
sure that there is enough hand sanitizer
for the countries yes it gives me also a
lot of confidence that if needed we can
use our current way of production and
production lines to actually create
different products so if it is possible
in times of crisis then in what other
situations might we also use what we
already have in terms of producing and
to achieve new products yeah so makes me
hopeful yeah and I do like the point
that you highlighted about the
collaboration between the two so that it
was also you have to change your
approach to developing right solution
but beside this this virus washing we've
seen it also in other times right could
you share a little bit more about other
cases of virus washing and not
necessarily during this pandemic right
during kovin 19 but we've had also other
crises before and companies have taken
advantage of trying to disclose large
quantity of ESG
data how they're doing well but in fact
they have poor ESG performance and so do
you have other examples which were out
out there before this pandemic yes what
what made this pandemic very clear is
that ultra-super knew and so now we're
already addressing greenwashing and what
we then see is that when you start
analyzing these patterns of human
behavior and of trying to survive during
times of crisis it's actually a
recurring thing so we now have the
pandemic which is leading to virus
washing but we have seen it in previous
crises before this example we know of
course that Americans can be much more
outspoken perhaps than consumers in Asia
but just give an example of a burger
chain that in the perspective of their
consumers really did not hit right own
when they were wanting to remember the
9/11 attacks so a different form of
crises or trauma this is the picture
that they posted to to remember that day
but then if you look at the right side
their Twitter channel and the way that
consumers responded or maybe their
opponents that's really not what you
want to achieve with your brands that
there is no correlation at all between a
cheeseburger and 9/11 and this is where
people point out and hold against you so
there is many many many more examples
like this so we can really see a pattern
on the next slides
um let's see we bundled this so we
started at strategizing and we bundled
this I think we can go back yeah bye bye
then addressing what is this pattern
that we see so you could call it crisis
washing and we've defined it as as seen
on screen as a less transparent and
honest approach to using a crisis for
your own benefit as a brand or
organization and yeah John what would
you like to add the finish up first all
right one of the emerging crises that we
have earmarks or that we will be faced
with as a global community in years to
come will be climate change and we've
seen instances of using sustainability
green communications marketing campaigns
that are focused on sustainable products
or services that are using this perhaps
existential threat in order to position
themselves in a certain way so moving
from crisis washing through virus
washing we would like to open up the
floor for green washing which we can see
on the next slide as a crisis or a
situation with which we will be faced
more and more in years to come and we
would like to inform the audience and to
make them savvy in helping them
understand what it actually means this
green washing attempts so being more
green or sustainable through your
advertising or marketing than you
actually are
putting your money to practice to become
environmentally more conscious or having
positive impact yep so it's a bit about
boosting what you're actually not really
doing in the sustainable space right yes
definitely
and we do understand that this is a very
fine line between being commercial and
being intrinsically motivated to do well
so instead of of presenting how you
would go wrong as a brand we would more
and I like to focus on how to do it
right yeah right so it's especially
relevant during those time of crisis
when people are mostly connected
digitally as we are right now right but
you have access to a lot of content and
information and as a brand you have a
role to make sure that you communicate
transparently and well with your
consumers because they also have access
to more information so there are
informed consumers they wouldn't just
buy in whatever you're posting but some
still do of course and that is why there
is so I believe some sorts of green or
crisis washing right yeah I think this
is a question that that John has all the
stats on how how savvy these consumers
are are becoming increasingly yeah I
mean we don't have the stats in this
presentation but as what you said I
think with social media being like
democratized quite a bit you know access
you can't really you control the flow of
information the gentian Millennial
audience which we call Generation Green
has access to way more than any of the
previous consumer groups in the past so
they have the ability to call brands out
for saying what they don't mean or
pretending to be something they're not
is we're seeing a sharp spike in that
you know I think signs are really
covered most of the topics ok so maybe
you would like to share with us an
example I think there are a few out
there that use bioplastic sustainable
circular message and whatsoever but can
you share a little bit more about an
example maybe yes definitely and we see
all these words being used in marketing
and potentially even in certification
that material would be biodegradable or
clip all sustainable and this would give
the consumer a sense of ease that it's
okay to use a certain material even if
it's single use because it's
biodegradable anyway but in the end
biodegradable means nothing more than
that
after I there's no claim on how many
years Earth may take to degrade it
actually so we could say that anything
is biodegradable in the end even a tire
of a charm but we know that for instance
a plastic bottle will take over 400
years to compost in nature so to give an
example of how that works and how that
could have an unwanted effect on your
breath you could see on the next slide
where we see that that Starbucks is
making a lot of effort to go really
looking at their packaging the material
making a claim about the way that their
coffee is sourced but there we also see
a claim about their straws and the straw
being biodegradable and one of our
community members here in Singapore he
put it to the test and actually very
distraught and we can see that he has
created a timeline of the degrade
ability of the products and it doesn't
happen so what we want to point out here
is that if you make a claim about a
straw that doesn't hold true then all of
the other claims that you would be
making about your environmental efforts
those would also may also turn out to be
false or perceived to be false and that
can be just as damaging to your brand so
this is something that we would want to
well
not touch upon when giving advice all
right
on the next slide so I just I see that
there are questions coming in I would
just like to remind if anyone has any
question at any point of time just drop
it in the Q&A function of zoom and then
we'll adjust them later but there is one
that just came in and I'm actually can
you
because some it's asking what a recycle
bility is the best okay that would
definitely be a question that I think
it's related to kind of the Starbucks
example here and this question just
comes in nicely yeah I feel that um
recyclability is one of the strategies
that we adapt or a dot but it's
definitely not the only one so when you
look at the recycling cycle it's
creating a product that is being reused
for as many times as possible or the
material is reused for as many times as
possible but in the end the recycled
product ends up being waste and from
circular economy practices we would say
that we are trying to avoid waste
altogether so if we can re manufacture
the material we would favor that over
recycling if we can reuse it repurpose
it so there is all these different kinds
of strategies and recyclability would be
a sort of last resort okay well we can
I'm sure we can talk a lot about this
topic so I'll avoid going into that and
remain on communication and branding
when it comes maybe to recycle bility
but so we talked about this case of
Starbucks right which applies not only
in Singapore but also world why I
believe is there any good practices that
you've seen in Singapore Joe maybe yeah
definitely I mean if you go to the next
slide so I mean one of the things that
really we saw a huge increase in was
food delivery I think during the
lockdown
everybody had to rely on either going to
take away food or getting food delivered
to their homes and you know seventy-two
percent increase in food delivery says a
lot during this circuit breaker and this
actually has such sparks sorry a large
amount of discussions around the need
for single-use country and plastic
packaging you know take away and
aquaculture so you know a lot of
concerns came up around whether or not
this is a this was how much impact it
was causing the environment with all the
I think if I remember correctly there
was an article that was being shared
around about how Singapore's actually in
the top ranks of ways largest producers
of waste around the world so if we go to
the next slide
so this is a campaign which I happen to
see a couple of weeks ago and you know
food Panda is a food delivery service
you know probably they are not the most
sustainable brand it comes to mind they
have never really communicate that yeah
commitment due to you know being a
sustainable brand heaven in every
position this is a great initiative and
trying to change the way change our
approach to single-use plastics by
regime businesses restaurants and people
to use reusable packaging so they
launched this campaign in partnership
and to have food live that using musical
packaging and I thought that was a great
come in by to local players here in
Singapore I mean sign you know the
founders maybe you want to talk a little
bit more to this the current single-use
packaging that we know in Singapore is
is mostly made out of styrofoam which is
really really cheap but also very toxic
so we don't really want to eat out of
this but it still happens and bear pack
is very much against this and have set
up a logistic system of reusable
packaging understandably because of the
covert 19 situation they needed to
rethink how this would influence take
away culture and delivery culture and
before the crisis foodpanda had like an
option in their app that you could leave
out any reusable utensils but now they
have turned that around completely so
that you can opt in the app that you
actually want to use the backpack system
and by this it becomes very very clear
how much of the impact that we saw on
the previous slide on of the food system
on waist related to the goal that crisis
can be mitigated so hopefully these 92
buses would decrease decrease effort but
what I really like about this example
that you judge says that food panga like
he said John has never over communicated
about their sustainable effort but when
they did they just simply told people
what they were doing and what they were
offering in their world over
communicating or over or trying to be
showed that there were so green as to
change the complete logo so I think that
that was a very powerful actually
approach to showing what efforts they're
trying to make into the sustainable
space or becoming more so clear as well
just before we go into you guys sharing
a little bit about your tips and
communication advices to better position
your brand right
we have a poll questions for the
audience yep I think it should have
appeared by now on your screen right so
when considering a green product or
services what argument is leaning in
your decision-making so we would like to
know for participants who are out there
you will have 30 seconds to enter to
this quick poll before we just want to
understand what you guys decide like
what are the factors that actually you
base your decision on but then I will
have Sun actually after this talk about
how to build a positive brand affinity
because we've understand their bad
practices under which you don't want to
fall accidentally mostly and so what are
the good practices yeah if you could go
to the next slide what we see and Shaw
already touched upon the today and
tomorrow's
consumers so that would mean like the
generation that remain agile and I are
part of but also the upcoming
generations they don't we don't choose
or buy products or services anymore just
because it is a prestige brand but
actually because it is clear how a
product is made by whom the environment
environmental impact that a product
might have is important to us so what we
see is that besides that we are
completely fine with commercial
activities we we agree everybody needs
to make money to survive in this world
so that's not what we have a problem
with but we do have a problem with for
instance in the fashion industry that
there is like terrible labor conditions
which is now directly linked to a brand
that we can see that if if we speak to
the same industry the environmental
impacts of residue die for clothing is
just that into a river now what that
does for the local flora and fauna so
what we see is that up coming in a and
current generations know they want to
know they want to know how by whom in
what fashion and this will create a
bonding to the brand so this is
definitely something to take into
account not only being transparent about
that you make money and how you make it
but also who is benefiting from it and
even if you are on the road to becoming
more sustainable this journey is more
important than already being there
because I don't think that any of us is
there already so it's much more
important to keep tests conversation
going and be honest about it but now I'm
already taking a head start about the
guidelines that we use when it comes to
helping organization brands and position
themselves better in these circumstances
so I guess we could maybe yeah I guess
we can maybe just jump directly in the
guide
but what I hear from what you just
shared now is actually it's really about
being transparent and not trying to
oversell right it's just stating simply
what you are doing and not necessarily
trying to share your ideal goals without
necessarily meeting them is just sharing
your journey towards those goals yeah I
agree I agree that's what we want to
hear right especially that we're more
informed but sorry please carry on you
know we put together just some takeaway
questions for brand managers or
designers that have logged in just
revisiting what is currently part of the
communication strategy and what parts of
that hold up during times of crisis so
what does it sound like during a crisis
is it still a message that you want to
get out there and how would you reply to
it if the company already has a
corporate social responsibility strategy
is it already in line with recurrent
crises or does it also apply to changing
situations and then the third one it
sounds a bit simple but just ask
yourself if you step outside of the
organization and you look at the
organization in a way that you
communicate can we actually look like
we're not exploiting a crisis okay can
we get it right yeah and this is
definitely questions that we have used
in order to set up guidelines and the
way that we support our clients and I
think that I would definitely hand over
to Jon right now I think this is it's
extremely relevant especially in
Singapore because I think we're all very
familiar with brands here jumping on
whatever that's trending and and and you
know I think this is like a little habit
that a lot of companies have been
Singapore I'm pretty sure you guys
remember when Joseph's schooling won a
gold medal suddenly every brand was
endorsing Singh at the Singapore Sun and
celebrating the win so you know we in
order to sort of like address whatever
that we were sharing earlier we have
prepared a set of guidelines to solve
like ask yourself or to guide you along
in when you're developing a plan based
on these questions there's honest answer
asked so if you go to the next slide
these are by no means like a to-do list
I mean again at the start of this
presentation Sun has really mentioned
they were not here to tell you what to
do why this is what you should do this
is the right way to do things this is
more more like a five-step approach that
both of us feel would be the best in
unlocking the right steps oh sorry - the
right steps to take not unlocking pardon
me so just to go over the steps one by
one you know we talked about harnessing
social influence and for all purposes we
are talking about speaking to the
general annual audience here they are
nonconformist by nature you know they
have a strong desire to really be higher
in a course they believed in in this
case sustainability so as my son
mentioned it's it's it's very important
for a brand to be brave and open and
honest with your communications you know
if you're taking your first step into
becoming more sustainability
communicated make the intent more
evident in your branding and
communications because this leads to
shaping good habits and we believe very
strongly their brands have a role to
play and it's not just in providing
their customers with a good product or a
good experience I think it's important
that as a brand you need to help your
customers make a commitment so for
example you use a festival a music
festival we've seen a lot of brands
create a simple exercise in encouraging
people to buy a reusable cup and by
doing so if you have a reusable cup in
every what you feel refills and this is
a good way to design features that
eliminate negative habits instead of
throwing or constantly throwing away
your cups you get to substitute if it's
a positive behavior that can you know
eventually affect incremental change so
once you started to do that you like we
encourage brands to build on the
momentum that was created because this
leads
good habits leads to positive spillover
and once you have started doing that own
it you know start your PR be consistent
in your messaging about using guilt as a
communication to instead build on the
positivity decided to create start small
think big you know as I mentioned the
example of Panda I thought this was a
very good effort by then by studying in
something small that they can change
information about sustainable behaviors
and the outcomes can normally be very
persuasive I think everybody nowadays is
very aware of the global effects about
how this information is framed your
consumers are pretty critical because
generation green wants to make a change
but again you know as a brand you need
to give them something to act on so
instead of lofty goals too far removes
from the consumer I think it's very
important to focus on what you can do at
a grassroot levels to incite action just
like what soup and last but not least
you know making sustainability resonate
through the communication is the
ambition that every brand should strive
to do because in that way it will
eventually build equity wave generation
green it will help you increase market
share and power movement towards a
culture of sustainable living so overall
these guidelines is we developed it to
sort of help you as a brand owner or a
bear market to understand and needs
alongside the barriers and benefits of
what sustainable marketing is until and
to tell your communications accordingly
okay thank you for sharing this I'm I'm
actually I'm curious you know because
it's a lot about communicating right and
at also the right timing
how about educating the consumer
actually because they might because
sustainability in circular economy are
both terms that are very much widely
used but some people don't actually know
what it is even so what do you think is
the role in for brands similarly to
Kitana I think how they did share that
everyone has a responsibility to share
that their toilet their essentials good
right with other people so in that sense
how how is that part of the guidelines
or is that not
part of the guidelines um Shawn would
you want to go first or because I think
you can go first okay
so the question the question is how
should a brand communicate that across
in there in an effective way correct
yeah and about more educating about the
sustainable topic right as a brand right
is that part of the role they should
take on so the whole set the whole
ecosystem sustainability can get very
daunting for a brand to do to take on by
itself right and Sanwa probably it was
add more to it because if you start
talking about sustainability practices I
think I should mention you know the the
right way to do it is to do we look at
the business model as a whole and look
at what your environmental impact but
you know when one of the points here
which I listed was start small and think
big and and how to make sustainability
resonate at a grassroots level and I
think a brand has a role to play there
you know and in every brand which is
either selling a product or services has
something along the supply chain in
which they could address to make
sustainability more evident or rather
change the way they do something to in
steps towards creating a more
sustainable brand I think is it's it's
the right thing to do is to focus on
these small other things and create
small steps in order to get your
consumers on board with this direction
they are taking a bit more technical
explanation about how our products are
actually made even if all of the
attention intentions of big brands and
and production companies would be
genuine and honest then still it's quite
hard to currently control every part of
information in your supply chain so what
we see is that if you approach it from a
greenwashing perspective some companies
might claim that they are 100%
sustainable but they
cannot back it up so there we can see
confusion when it comes to the
perception of the consumer because the
consumer just wants to be able to trust
the label what we see however is both
consumers becoming more knowledgeable
and wanting to know more and on the
other side pressure from governments
that are demanding more transparency so
even if it would not be intrinsically in
the motivation of the organization to be
so transparent this will increasingly
become so so to answer your question and
I do believe it's part of the
responsibility of the brand or
organization to inform and educate for
those that are in the need to know and
that can take a variety of forms most
importantly and this is something that
John has already touched upon as well
take what you know so start with what
you know and start building from there
so it can be one product it can even be
one ingredients that you know that you
can trace that can you can share the
story about start with that and start
building then we'll get there because if
we always think about you know the the
negativity that surrounds like if you're
gonna stop being worried about what
people would think in that sense you're
always gonna just not do anything and I
mean if I use the backpack example I
think we have a very relevant question
there which we can answer after this
the whole thing the whole thing
surrounding this the sustainability
campaign you know it's reducing plastic
waste but you know the whole idea around
delivering food it's in itself is not
sustainable because of the amount of
petrol and the amount of transport that
requires people to be on the move
constantly so then you know you you you
you can find yourself in a situation but
where you know should we even do this
because that part of the business is not
sustainable and we are what we're trying
to say is you should you know because
it's the right step forward and and it's
and if you can you know create some
change in the in a part of the business
which would resonate with your consumers
do it
I will read the question out loud um
it's um one of the participants asking
the food panda bear pants and pain if
bear pack is recyclable how is it
reusable so that actually has a saving
of poor wide logistics system that
collects and cleans the material so they
have a whole network of restaurants and
vendors that work with them and in that
way they are able to reuse the material
again and again and again so it's both
the boxes and cups I hope this answers
the question you know please feel free
to drop any question because we will
have a few minutes to spend on Q&A later
otherwise it's me who will be I have
tons of questions always coming in when
we top this topic you can talk about
this topic because it's super
interesting but before this I'll be
going back to this final slide before
leaving the floor to design Singapore so
thank you so much joy and Sam for
sharing a little bit about your
knowledge on do's and don'ts and giving
some super interesting actually case
study both worldwide and in Singapore
maybe I would like to know how the two
company you work together in developing
this positive message sure um I'll tell
you my challenge so most of the
innovations that so now worked with come
from very technical people that have the
future in their hands but don't know how
to communicate about it so we need a way
to to find the way to market for these
in attempts and these news new ways of
thinking so that's one side of this
vector and then on the other side we are
confronted five powerful market parties
that want to use this strand in order to
to present themselves as being more
sustainable or keeping their position in
the market while perhaps it's time to
change so
we were actually looking for a part
getting away at our experience about
technical innovations climate change
which which can feel as a big threat and
the power of big companies and to turn
that around into something that is very
appealing and fun and aspiring so oh
that's where we find ultra super new
great well thank you again son and Joe
for bringing us through this very
insightful presentation and again we'll
have time for questions later on but
before continuing on the question part I
would like to invite Michelle from
design Singapore council to share a bit
more about a work that they do at the
council so Michelle please hi everyone
this is Michelle from design Singapore
Council thanks Romina Shaun and John for
the sharing definitely great advice
there especially in times like these so
just a quick shout out about the design
thing about council we've been around
since 2003 and we're the national agency
in Singapore championing the growth of
the design sector our ultimate vision is
to help Singapore become an innovation
driven economy and a livable city by
design by 2025 so you'll be asking what
has design gonna do with branding at all
well design is all about the ability to
empathize with user needs it's about
developing a deep understanding of
customers challenges especially with
times like that when there's changing
consumer attitudes as well as behaviors
having that understanding would allow
you to be like what the speakers have
said earlier be able to build positive
brand affinity with your customers so
your brand represents who you are what
you believed in and how would you like
how you would want to be perceived by
your audience and getting that balance
is key especially in times like these so
here the design team work on so we've
also rolled out several initiatives
which would be useful for both
businesses as well as designers
some of these initiatives provide
support for businesses looking to
reposition themselves their products as
well as their services we also have
support for exploratory studies into
identities as well as culture so do
visit our newly revamped website designs
guru org to know more details so for
those of you who are not aware the
council is also in charge of the
programming at a National Design Center
so if you guys don't know national
design centers middle road so in your
bouquets area we believe in putting out
timely and highly curated topics of
interest and initiatives that will give
our stakeholders as well as businesses a
first-hand glimpse into what's shaping
the world as well as what's shaking up
the world so you'll see on your screen
right now
um there's many design activities and
events that we've been planning out
under normal circumstances
these programs such as our exhibitions
workshops and talk would have taken
place at the National Design Center in a
physical sense so we definitely look
forward to welcoming you back at the NDC
as soon as we can
meanwhile we've been working with great
partners like chemistry so now ultra
super new to bring you webinars like
this as well as regular content through
our digital channels so like Romina
mentioned at the start today's session
is part of the national design centers
program lineup in June with a genetic
focus on building strong brands so this
series of content that we're putting out
will help inform brands as well as SMEs
on how they can refine their branding
strategies to find out more about other
programs in the lineup you can scan the
QR code that you're seeing on your
screens right now to see in details what
are the other programs are coming up you
can even catch some of these sessions
other sessions that you've missed so you
can subscribe also to our newsletters to
stay updated with all these exciting
events coming up so that's all from my
site I'll hand it back over to Rome you
know thank you so much Michelle and I
was just gonna say it like we work also
forward to attending physically the
events rather than digitally although
this format has been quite smooth so far
I hope it has been smooth for us then
for you guys who are attending this
webinar but we really look forward to
going back to the centre to attend some
of the great event that you usually
organize yeah so now it's time for a Q&A
section so I see that son you've
actually started answering to some of
them but I would like maybe you can
share about it I think that bear pack is
actually very good or an interesting
case study for people out there because
they're asking how they collect actually
a pack or rather than how they return
this this talk where have you guys
actually used a bear pack or do you know
by its how it works I haven't had the
chance please I haven't ordered food
recently but yeah for sure
they give they have a whole network
across Singapore with offenders
restaurant owners they started more in
the social space so the cafes that have
that aim to have a social impact or that
are focused on plant-based diets or
sustainable living but from there they
understood that the bigger challenge
would be at well the mainstream cafes
and restaurants as well so they have
been building this whole network of
contractors and for the owners of the
restaurant or the food service they give
instructions on how to clean these
materials so that they can reuse and
then there is an app for the user and it
will register what you want to pick up
and from there it's both like offline
and online tracking so you can return it
to any of the vendors that you like you
don't have to return it to the same
restaurants but all of the restaurants
involved know how to clean yeah yeah
I've used the trace sorry well I also
know that they are still
improving on the system as well so there
there will be more innovations as part
of how to keep these boxes in use well
that that I look forward to see how it
will become a new normal
I know there are a few other concepts
that allow you to bring your own cup and
use at the top where I see also more and
more actually the younger generation who
just intuitively take Tupperware's
and containers to top out their food
right agree agree so the for this
service I used to take like but it's
heavy I usually take like the boxes with
me because I didn't want to contribute
to the waste and that's something that
isn't necessary now anymore because I
know that my favorite restaurants have
their service Oh
another question is coming in expanding
on branding strategy during coded 19
both positive and negative example were
shared would you like to ask to what
extent and time frame should company
still mention about Kovich better
position our brand in a good light
before it comes across as used and old
that's a very good one
maybe he's all you would like to tackle
it yeah it's a great question and
something which we've asked ourselves a
few times as a you know our clients and
even with recent
lives matter movement we had a we had
several discussions internally whether
or not it was insensitive to be still
posting about campaign when everyone
else is posting about life matters was
it going to be detrimental to us we were
people start reacting negatively to the
brand and I'll just share first what we
decided was the right approach and this
of course this is just just our agency
of course I mean the first thing is to
ask yourself whether or not your brand
has any direct relation to
the crisis that you're men talking about
whether or not you know you in that
sense have the right to do do do to
share something
I'm not saying that you know you can't
post messages of solidarity oh you're
not saying that you can't post messages
of encouragement you can but you know
you need to you need to ask yourself the
intent behind this messaging what's
what's the objective that you're trying
to achieve in in in putting our
communications out there because you can
be sure that people on the other end is
gonna be asking the same questions of
your brand you know is this guy doing it
just to do to get more awareness or you
know is he actually doing something
about it so in your in your question
another example which is not that that
was was razor you know I think razor was
a rather if I could say mixed opinion
you know some people thought what they
were doing in readjusting their entire
supply chain to produce box was the
right thing to do but even then some
people perceived it to be an opportunity
for them to get it here so ultimately
you have to just ask yourself like what
the true intent of your communications
is and if it's it and it becomes from a
place of sincerity and generally please
but I want me to go ahead I don't think
it ever there's no timeline that I can
set to becoming a user all because if
you start thinking about whether or not
it's relevant now I rather than been
then perhaps maybe the message you know
it's not the right way and I think you
have to be agile and there is something
that um as design thinker or taking all
this human centered design approach I
think sometimes it's okay to ask
actually your audience what they want to
hear from you taking I mean taking this
user centric and customer centric
approach right if you don't know what to
communicate about I think it's best just
to ask your user what they want to know
and how they would like to know also
what's the best communication method or
what are the channels or should it be
longer a short way of course I guess we
all need to be agile and fast enough
during those times of the pandemic to be
able to answer quickly I think we're
almost running time
and I don't see any other questions so I
will take this opportunity to ask a
question actually I wanted to because
taking this design I mean this is a
business design approach right I'm
interested to know right well how would
you what would be the first step when
you design a new campaign or design a
new solution how should you um when do
you start thinking about communicating
the right way your sustainable a
circular message and maybe son you can
answer this one I well that's that's
from the circular economy perspective
right only in the design phase of how he
treats our materials can we have an
influence on their entire use cycle so
starting with design thinking at the
basis so when you're at the drawing
boards that's that's the only way you
can in the end completely control or be
accountable or responsible yeah thank
you son now before we have finished we
have the results for the poll so I think
now we can share it with you let me oh
there you go
oh so the winner is you make decision on
the product or service that contributes
to my lifestyle okay very interesting
what do you think guys think about this
the results it's quite it's quite nice
to see that actually yeah for me because
I'm so deep into the subject and I also
get biased so this is very good to see
what actually drives people in their
buying decisions and I think the choice
of building this lifestyle that you want
to contribute to or be a part of that
might be one of the strongest drivers
out there or change so very happy with
these results yeah very good to see so
I just see that we're running a little
bit over the time so I'm just gonna end
this webinar so we would like we need to
thank you all for joining us this
evening and hope that you have gained
some interesting insight Thank You y'all
son and Michelle for making this webinar
happen yeah thank you for for everything
and keep safe stay safe yeah and have a
very pleasant evening goodbye everyone
thank you all thank you everyone bye